car j'avais l'air très en forme déjà que
ça va la santé excellent excellent c'est
vrai je fais quelques envieux
un parmi mes petits camarades fait ce
qu'on prend comme faire une petite
interview de chez kate
diack qu'est ce qui vous rend malade
quand vous venez à la télé le trac
oh ben ça va mieux là puis quelques
instants
beauvais ouais qu'est ce qui vous donne
mal à la tête aujourd'hui dans les
discours de jacques chirac
un sorte de vide 1
mais l'homme vaut parfois mieux que ses
discours
qu'est ce qui vous fait vomir dans le
gouvernement de villepin actuellement
l'art du mensonge
qu'est ce qui vous fait mal au coeur
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez sarkozy
sa voix de karcher
qu'est ce qui vous fait vous arracher
les cheveux au ps aujourd'hui ce que je
manque de cheveux non pas vous qu'est-ce
qui vous filent un ulcère conviennent
journal de 20 heures sur tf1 le
l'enfilade de kata
quel homme politique vous donne le plus
de boutons pas un homme politique c'est
ce régime politique dans lequel nous
vivons qui me donne beaucoup de boutons
c'est pourquoi il faut le changer
qu'est-ce qui vous démange en ce moment
l' envie de me battre et de gagner la
dernière fois que votre coeur s'est
arrêté de battre c'était pour qui pour
monique à venir qu'est ce qui vous a mis
la fièvre pour la dernière fois
gilberto gil 20 14 juillet place de la
bastille qu'est-ce que vous prenez comme
excitant dans la vie le boulot le
travail je me shoote au travail un peu
de cocaïne quand même pas besoin de
travail le temps à parler je suis un
drogué du boulot à quelle idée êtes-vous
allergique à tout ce qui porte atteinte
à la dignité humaine
quel chanteur de charme au fil du
diabète à ses mauvaises heures dominique
de villepin qu'est ce que vous entendez
moins bien en vieillissant pardon et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou